with those can you please put the hands
up again so those people might not be
experienced with mob programming so we
now we need to find a way to incorporate
them to existing team in in our existing
teams or maybe build new games where
they can join and and learn this with
you
I mean I mean you can have your own team
but do you have somebody who is familiar
with more programming and can facilitate
it okay awesome then let's then you do
it and you facilitate it and then you
that's fine
do we continue with pedantic like the
same exercise we did in the first class
there's a different exercise with this
part
are you already finished with the
exercise
I would say if you're not finished uh
just continue with the exercise and if
there is some something else you want to
work on work on something else okay yeah
could you commit could you commit what
we've done in the first session or is it
not the intention or
[Music]
um
why would you like to commit
you can just do new stuff
like you have my permission to do new
stuff yeah you can add anything you want
really
but the question was about the code that
we did all together in in the group
I'm I I guess we will commit that and
push that and at some time but like you
can create your own bra your you can
Fork I mean you have to you'll have to
Fork it I don't think you can push to
that repo yeah I think you have to do
like a pull request and stuff so
I think we'll do new things anyway
the point is that we learn more
programming it's not so much about
writing code today so
yeah
to know and if you want to work on
something else you'll be my guest
thank you
so for the new people who came in that's
a GitHub link so
foreign
you will join this group okay awesome
exactly you'll find it
[Music]
um
if you have any questions
[Music]
are you rotating yeah
uh
foreign
[Music]
I'm talking about abcsis
is
restraints
um
there was a range
foreign
they had like a runaway
yeah I I like this guy me too yeah
production
thank you
this is crazy switch by itself right
yeah yeah no I switched the uh sorry ah
you switched it okay
yeah okay okay
[Music]
[Applause]
audience
it must be a reason is it a talk or is
it I think it was just an attack that he
was
I think there's some website where they
have more programming anti-patterns
I know of one side it's about mobbing
patterns
by from yeah Alliance
I think the same place they have antique
patterns
tomorrow
uh yeah I think it's on the schedule
sorry I'm just gonna finish I want to
finish this
man
no it's fine
anti-pattern The Fight Club
you know riding shotgun
can you can you send me the link to this
page this is
yeah
I just agile Alliance things but the
patterns there a bit prescriptive what I
like more is
the anti-patterns yeah because it's like
sure what because the patterns they're
doing there they came up with them like
they're good for them yeah
switch it up
it's off but it's on
maybe it doesn't work
yeah switch doesn't work
I I turn it off but it's still
fun
is table about limits and limits in the
book actually I should probably look at
the book
what are you using for books
I would also like to have some cross
team learning so when we have a retro
that we like do we do some retro also
together I would like to listen to what
the team's noticed and by the time we
once we put the chairs in line the teams
will be dead like physically dismantling
them once you put the chairs on the line
so
so we have we're gonna have two Retros
one on the team yeah they just had the
rental right now like there's nothing
at least another 15 minutes or 20
minutes of cutting what do you think do
we first like first we need the Retros
in the teams it will be the first thing
and then do we then start putting
together the chairs or do we then have a
retro now because we put together chairs
and the teams are closed yeah to become
one big mom and then we do the general
retro and we close together let's do it
this way and then you will show your
page
through
it's a nice person
foreign
making myself busy if they are
interested they will find their contents
they will find talks and the things that
they like yeah
it's also interesting that this
code has different shapes I put it like
that if I can create it I create it like
that but I chose it I didn't know it
works like that too you can make
where you like it you can put it on Logo
into it and stuff
yeah I wanted to be different to the
other stuff
so
yeah I want to finish with the
like this is my final slide yeah how
long do you need for this line like two
minutes two minutes yeah and you want to
do it in the very end after you
so I think for the final retro we need
something like 15 minutes all right
and then if your slide maybe together
it's like I don't know 17.
17 minutes or something
for putting the chairs together also
like
few minutes just sitting down as well
yeah that's calculated
so
I think we can already start encouraging
them
to have Retros in their teams and then
in 10 minutes we start doing everything
we should be finished
right that was scheduled time at five it
says for them
like it's not
lightning talks
start uh at five
I thought we should be finished
I wonder if we finished buying stocks
and it's like I started at 5 20. so yeah
so finishing at five I think would be
good yeah I agree
yeah so it's it's now in 40 minutes for
40 minutes left
yeah
so
so let's have them have a retro now and
then oh I said to maybe wait a little
bit maybe it's every 10 minutes
let's make 10 more minutes and then
for 16. so for the
big retro
at least eight minutes right
yeah I would take more I would think so
it seems like there's a lot of talking
you know I want them to I'm not enough
coating that's what they always say
about agile there's a lot of talking
more programming no more programming
example you don't need Retros ideally
like
I think the sort of
good communication
um what do you actually want so sure
let's give them 15 more minutes and 16
45 will start okay yeah let's do it this
way okay
the timer
oh cool
do you have a chain chain time
it says in the red me I think yes I know
1700 to 1900.
in
14 minutes
and
we will have
my pictures
[Music]
yes
and um
following half deaths yeah
Deliverance
or
um
that's how I thought this happened and
the third person
um
everything
is
right
now everybody can enjoy
45 things
it down
a centralized
35 right and can you repeat what comes
first first
smoking stretcher than tables and chairs
and then
and then your slide and then final retro
or first Finance
yeah okay
you can but language
spiciest stuff
it was a spice here
that sounds fine for me yeah
I think they're not going to start the
red for even when the challenge so
they're still going to finish the round
yeah yeah he still likes us all exactly
exactly yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's a good idea do you want your
Twitter here
like you have your whole role-playing
game and stuff
yeah can I talk to them about that
um
I mean yeah
it's in typescript so I don't know
um
sure yeah sure just put our contacts or
something I don't know can you maybe
open up uh Google and search for more
programming RPG
yeah but no no this one go back exactly
um
yeah something like that
uh this one yeah
and just maybe just uh
click here
and add a player
just left for I don't know
if I come yeah
exactly an edit
yeah
and click add
and maybe add one more player
and now I don't know around three points
here just to
before it's fine like this it's fine can
you make a screenshot of that and bring
it onto the
and make it a little bit smaller
exactly yeah
uh public mob
the public mob on the more programming
RPG
and can you make also uh I don't know a
code with this link yep
just to make a suggestion here because
um
everyone says
something very complicated but can you
not just screenshot it
will this work see if it works now
and just bring it I don't know over here
or here in the corner yeah do you think
this will work yeah
you can also make the game screenshot a
little bit smaller Maybe
[Music]
they write this in type type script
no no I will tell them every time and
maybe uh can you give my Twitter handle
yeah below below that link
bigger and underscore regular I think
yeah
that's it yeah
thank you
sometimes
yeah I think then let's
uh
let's intro let's have them
call out for Retros that's okay if I do
this
yes okay
do you want do you want to make it or to
die is the time I think if we have two
slides we will take a little bit more
time
okay okay
let's let's write a little bit
see how far they got
yeah we can we can see that in the Retro
thing yeah
questions
so it should be doing
um
foreign
is
one second
[Music]
particularly
um
how are things
let's type up the questions
what was interesting
for the small group return same question
so I would say
um
I think they're having a retro all the
time so they are often talking about
a small group
yeah and our suggestion is to have a
restaurant yeah yeah
can I start yeah
okay folks
um
um so there is now 10 minutes left for
you to stay in your groups I encourage
you to do a retrospective again and talk
about how things went a little bit what
react well how did it feel and
then we will do something else
so please just know that's going on for
10 more minutes yeah
I like
or maybe you guys are having ongoing
retrospective and you don't want to
spend 10 minutes just talking maybe
you're just like talking as you type so
maybe you just want to code for 10
minutes more it's your choice sometimes
in more programming we don't have Retros
we just do retro as we go continuous
retro
[Applause]
[Music]
some of the people somebody I mean they
can it's an option like then they can
they they I saw this group voting like
thumb up thumb down in neutral really
yeah if you want to have a retro like
this then
they decided to keep putting it
which is nice like they just met and
they already decide something to do yeah
this is how how our startups grow
or not
like I've been in startups where it's
like the founder has too many queue of
reviewing cars
[Music]
I mean this is always probably right
really well for like you know hiring if
you are like an engineering manager you
can code and then you can Photoshop a
paper and then there's something sending
out you want to hire them it's a perfect
opportunity and that much more expires
by pairing you can cut works you pair
people during the interview in any
language you want
the mobbing is even better yeah because
you have to argue yeah and collaborate
yeah
10 45 right yes
they know exactly how to challenge for
me the guy come up and explain how the
church should be I think I would prefer
him to do it
I would just ask him to bring up the
state of the chairs like they have been
um
[Music]
foreign
I hope this will work quickly with the
chairs
so that we have enough time for these
lights and Direction yeah you know
I mean but if we go a little bit into
the break
the physical chairs in this room yeah
foreign
[Music]
about it
and give the Retro one more minute to
wrap it up
[Music]
like a lot of them are actually it gets
interesting right yeah and there are
many ways to do the validator as I
learned today which I didn't know before
it helps a lot of the debugging
especially the assertions
and I invite you to say good I invite
you to say goodbye to the small team now
this is our last activity in small teams
the next activity we'll be acting is one
big Ensemble again we have a request
from yanis from BCC to work together to
put the chairs back in line
and there's Giannis in the back who will
correct you about it so yeah that's me
hi
yeah just let's put the chairs in some
lines and when he said goodbye to the
small team and come back to the big
group exactly in the checkbook
but but please stay even even after the
chairs are aligned please stay in the
room because we will still have a big
retro to learn from each other how what
we learned in each of your teams yeah
like I really like the arrangement of
the physical space
is
okay
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
sorry
is just
desserts yeah
[Music]
welcome back to the big group in a
couple of in a couple of minutes we'll
start the big retro
foreign
thank you all for putting the chase back
yeah
foreign
okay thank you for bringing back the
seats so let's use a little bit of time
to learn about what you found
interesting in your groups in your teams
is there something that we want to share
so one one question
is when you like you have this moment
when someone who's like really
experienced with like maybe pedantic and
someone is a complete beginner do you
when do you start like explaining
because if you like explaining for three
minutes the channel is almost over
it's it's totally okay to use a turn
just for explaining and when there is
somebody who is rather beginner I
experienced that it's nice to have them
as a driver and be typing and have the
person who is more experienced talking
um that it it helps for transferring
knowledge
yeah
I'm actually picking up right right on
that point uh What uh I found in our
group was very helpful was the role of a
facilitator to have a look on
um if the disbelance happens that one
person talks too much and that you then
as a group rather decide to switch the
context from a solver programming to a
quick Tech breakout or something and
that helps helped a lot to have this
facilitator role in beer yeah yeah also
like I or experience a lot where like a
mob just pauses the timer and then has
an ongoing discussion for 10 15 minutes
about technical stuff of for design or
maybe they want to draw something and
then they just go on coding after that
for me the the most interesting was that
we managed to make a sec fault so I
didn't expect that
no but jokes aside I think
I actually learned more in a shorter
amount of time than I would have if I
would have to look up myself things
because the best moments are when when
we become this kind of Mega brain you
know that's yeah you instantly learn
from each other
and this is otherwise you need to spend
a lot of time and look up different
answers but if somebody's already
experienced these issues then it's it's
easier it's faster and this I would I
was surprised because it's
communication is slower than thinking
but you know yeah true yeah that's a
bottleneck but I'm glad you had that
experience
anyone else yeah there is some thing to
mention
yes one thing that we discussed in our
group uh was uh that we we had started
with a very detailed task list how does
this Ensemble programming look like if
you don't start with very much like
let's say a user story or less
yeah
that's a good question so you noticed uh
with this exercise that we did sneak in
test driven development so you had to
write tests make it fast and so and so
on and so forth when it comes to uh to
use a story driven development or
something like that
um it doesn't change much it's just that
the person who is talking has to decide
what we're gonna do next
um and I would say yeah you just have to
have to try it it's just
a little a little different it's just
maybe uh not that guided in a way like
there's more freedom I would say yeah
I thought it was really interesting how
difficult it is to
um instruct someone on how to manipulate
text like just you know oh you need to
take these few lines and copy them into
this function or move this thing around
and it's actually you know in my head I
think I'm speaking extremely clearly but
then
the person's doing something completely
different and I don't know I guess text
editing is yeah hard to communicate
yeah it's yeah it's it's also you you
you get better at communicating your
intent and what you want to do and to be
precise and to talk slowly and simply I
think doing more programming more often
yeah
so we did this with pie dancing so what
is the big advantage to doing it with
pedantic
are not without
like
I did the same exercise with DBT for
example and there's like DBT data
validation package like I'm thinking of
doing the same thing with Pandera
and if you do the same five people it's
with pedantic with Pandera like DBT
the Great Expectations then you will
know us five people what you prefer
yeah
I mean that's that's a known answer but
my idea is to experiment and and to try
it on the toy problem with all the tools
that you have some some teams love
Pandera because they work with pandas
and it works really well for them some
some teams like row by row you know
typed classes and they use pedantic but
it's all of those packages have their
fans
that brought me to the next question
um what is your experience with um
editor Wars
yeah like the reason we use gitpod even
though it looks like this code but it's
not exactly this code so that's that's
like one way out of editor Wars I do it
I do this online as a Meetup and we
always use gitpod to get out of people
who don't have these code installed
and I like using the same editor as
other people in my team because I like
learning typing skills like being a good
typist is actually a hard skill it's
like being a good race car driver like
you know your shortcuts you know all
automatic refactoring which is there
like it's I like learning typing skills
from others so I like being on the same
IDE as other people
I I got two technical questions on that
note does gitpod allow for collaborative
editing
wow great
um second question yeah we we had a
little bit of
um and the biggest impediment was
probably the keyboard layout
oh you know that okay good uh any any
hints what helps
just use German keyboard layout yeah
yeah I agree on that just use it which
looks so the best way I know is if you
work on the same keyboard to just deal
with it
if you can manage to everybody work on
your own keyboard then that's maybe even
better working remotely gives you this
opportunity
also for the first question
um what was the first question again I
had something to say about it
collaborate editing exactly so there is
one limitation to gitbot gitbot works
very well if only one person changes a
file at the same time if multiple people
join the same gitbot session and they
both change the same file at the same
time there will be conflicts
I mean of course there are other like
Visual Studio code plugins that allow
for more collaborative editing but
typically we don't need it because there
is only one typist changing a file so
it's fine
yeah
do we have more questions or like on the
big retro group
um no we don't have any more questions
but we have two more slides also if
there is but there is a question I think
yeah yeah
yeah I just wanted to mention that I
really like the jetbrains things because
if everybody uses them you can even
remote control the the terminal session
and execute tests and everything so I
really like that but I never had a
project where the customer actually gave
us a daily Chase so I only use it
privately so far
awesome then maybe let's go to the final
slides
so
um I'm running every Thursday a public
mob programming we are working on the
more programming RPG it's the mobile
programming RPG is actually not
developed by me or by us it's developed
by William Larson the idea is developed
by William Larsen and we are making a
web page to be able to play the mob
programming RPG together with friends
and it's it's a way to teach more
programming in a in a gamification style
yeah so so so you just play the game you
got the points and the goal is to have
fun and we are we are programming uh
together this tool every Thursday and we
mob on it and everybody can join you can
join if you want
um but it's written in typescript so
it's not it's not python I'm actually
I'm not a very deep into python or I do
a lot of python I just do very little
he's much better patent than I am
um yeah and you can also you can find me
on Twitter and and so on if you would
you like to
and
there is something
life is doing yeah so I'm I really want
to bring more programming into the data
python community and there's Meetup
called Berlin data Crafters which is
online so you don't have to be in Berlin
to join and we meet online in gather
town and we use gitpod to do more
programming together like we've done
this exercise there December we've done
some DBT we've done model framework
and next week I want to do long chain
you know maybe a pedantic validation of
long chain output or maybe something
more simple with long chain if you are
curious I'll be you're very welcome to
join next week just we'll also post
those links in the in the Discord in the
channel for this room Channel
so I think that that would also be
possible those links for your group and
also the event
yeah
are there any final questions or
comments
yeah there's a question there
often we have to defend or sell this
idea of five or more people mobbing
together
can we just sum up our like most
important and strongest arguments why
this is a good idea
that's a that's a good question so
I
I would
step away from trying to argue why it is
a good idea maybe you can just ask if
you could make an experiment for a
limited amount of time
and then have the people doing the
experiment giving the feedback whether
they think it works or not and why and
see what comes out of it and
maybe this sort of feedback that you
that you've maybe maybe you find out it
works very well for you and then it will
keep on going so I think I think using
experiments time framed experiments are
a good way to
uh get into it and also argue about it
yeah like starting more programming in a
team that doesn't do that that's a very
big change and they're like big books
written how introduce changed an
organization and you start slowly you do
it one hour a week of small puzzles as a
toy and then maybe you do it on the
production code for four hours you know
once a month and then you slowly people
get more relaxed about it
if they like it and maybe they don't
like it and that's also a good outcome
as well there's a question I think it's
really a chance for Knowledge Management
um and once you are set up with such an
experiment and you're comfortable to
invite the manager and then they'll see
the disciplined style of it and I think
that
should could help
are there any more questions or yeah is
anyone typing on slido2 so that I can
also
okay
I mean there are a lot of agile coaches
who can talk about management and making
your industry more agile but it's more
about management this kind of technical
coaching which is Greg is training is
already one actually that's another kind
of coaching we'll actually see through
you encode and teach you how to code and
speak like that is very like Hands-On
micro coaching and I think that helps an
organization sometimes the transition if
you have somebody like that that's my
plug for Greg
so thank you thank you on that note I
actually I want to end the sessions
before that will you put on the slides
somewhere the link okay that would be
also also on the Discord channel so
we'll put some links on the Discord
Channel too so thank you all for
attending the sessions and yeah let's
thank the presenters again
thank you
so yeah if anyone is tweeting yeah
remember the hashtags and thank you all
for attending again and yeah I hope
you'll have a great day again the social
event is on the lightning talks are on
So yeah thank you